[Music]
hi welcome to the animation talk on
Friday afternoon we are opposite a
Kotlin talk so I think that means that
everybody in this room didn't want to
hear about Kotlin which is perfect
because we don't have any Kotlin on our
slides so welcome to the not Kotlin talk
I am Chet Haase I'm from the Android UI
toolkit team I'm Doris Lu I'm also
Angela I took a team and we're going to
tell you a little bit actually a lot
about animation we're going to talk
about small changes that were made to
the existing animator stuff small but
very important and deceptively tricky to
implement features but more importantly
Doris is going to tell you all about a
new physics based animation system
starting right about now clicker alright
so today I'm going to talk about physics
facing images you might be asking why
would we need a physics based animation
library a few years ago before I joined
the android framework team I was up an
app developer just like some of you I
wanted to create a swipe animation for
the Google camera app and had the camera
menu moving in a beautiful waveform
along with a gesture I'd also track the
velocity of the gesture up until this
moment of finger release then I thought
to myself alright now the only thing
that's missing in this is getting the
camera menu to continue the momentum of
the gesture once the finger is released
so I looked in view of the end Android
animation framework for an API that can
take velocity as one of the starting
conditions and close the gap for me I
looked and looked and there was no such
API if you've had similar experience
building animations in your apps you're
in luck because today we're going to
talk about the new physics based
animation library that we have just
released you might be asking how is this
you physics-based animation library any
difference than the existing animation
API well if you're familiar with the
existing animation API you know in order
to create its animation you will need to
provide a start value end value duration
and an interpolator velocities that's
just an afterthought once such an
animation is created velocity has to be
derived from other properties of the
animations given that it's extremely
difficult to create an animation that
can continue the momentum of the gesture
once once you know that's leading up to
the animation but with physics based
animations or it can handle the
different gestures with the different
velocities much easier from different
gestures from small swipe to a really
fast play also because the movements of
the animation in the new system are
governed by real-world physics they look
more natural and lifelike and the new
system can also respond to updated user
input and dynamically change the target
value of the animation during the
animation now let's take a look at how
different an animation system handle
this park evaluate change during the
animation here we're using a an object
animator I think some of you might be
familiar with us and the target value is
indicated by the position of the green
ring on the bottom as you can see the
ring had moved before the animation is
finished and usually the way we handle
this is we would stop we would be
canceled the ongoing animation and then
we configure the animation using the new
end value and then starting it again for
the problem with that is as you can see
it leads to already sudden and abrupt
change in the movement and if we look at
the velocity chart for this animation
the blue and red curved in here
represent the velocity action white
at the moment of target value change the
velocities are dropped immediately back
down to zero and that's because we're we
have canceled the ongoing animation and
then the velocities will start changing
again once the new animation starts but
this discontinuity in velocity can
create a really jarring experience for
the user
in contrast here's physics based
animation and when the target value has
changed in physics based animation we
interpret that as a change in the
physics force and then the new force
will continue to act upon the existing
velocity of the object which is why we
won't see a velocity discontinuity and
in this example we can see so the
transition to the new new target
position is really smooth and similarly
let's together the velocity chart I
would no longer seeing any discontinuity
in the velocity and that is the key to a
smooth animation at this point you might
be asking so what exactly is the physics
pace innovation the way we define it is
it's an animation that's driven by force
and based on the force we can calculate
the acceleration or deceleration which
we can then use to calculate an update
the velocities and values for the
animation until finally when the force
which is equilibrium that's our signal
to stop the animation first let's take a
look at sling animations so animation
starts with the initial velocity and
usually that's the velocity of your
gesture and then it will continue that
momentum and then gradually comes to
stop the force behind the animation is a
friction force which is proportional to
the velocity what that means is velocity
will undergo an exponential decays in
the duration of the animation and that
will produce a very graceful end to the
animation and by the way the swing
animation is exactly the AVI
was looking for years ago when I was
building animation for the camera wrap
now let's be an example for the full
animation here as you can see em fling
this list from left to right then the
orange dot is indicating the position of
my finger and the list just took off at
the same velocity of my gesture and then
gradually come to a rest now let's see
how this is achieved in order to get
notified when a fling gesture occurs we
need to create a gesture listener and
once the fling Jack's gesture is
detected we received a song fling
callback with the down event and up
events and velocity both X and y-axis I
will be using and they'll be in the unit
pixels per second which is also the unit
that we'll be using for the velocities
in the new animation system and now
we're ready to create a swing animation
to the constructor of the play animation
we need to provide the object we want to
animate in this case it's the list of
bearded injuries and they probably they
won't animate in this case that is the
correct since we want to fling this list
horizontally and then we're going to set
the start velocity here you can see I
have universe the velocity of the
gesture and that's because here we're
animating the squared property the
squirrel property is sort of special in
that a positive change in the scroll
value would actually move the list in
the opposite direction as a positive
velocity would and then we're also going
to set melodia Max value to define the
range for this animation play animation
would end immediately once it reaches
either it's me ladder or max value and I
would encourage you to set a good value
range for your animations so that as
soon as the animation goes off screen it
should stop right away otherwise the
animation might go on for too long
without making any change on screens Wow
is why we would request for redraws and
consume a lot of battery and finally
we're setting friction to control the
rate of deceleration now we're ready to
start so this is all it takes to create
a fling animation now let's take a
closer look at a sling friction here I'm
going to create a animation for the view
scroll wide property with a starting
velocity of 5,000 pixels per second and
the friction of 1.1 and then I'm going
to create another animation with the
exact same setup except we're going to
double the friction and if we run these
two animations side-by-side we can see
how the friction affects the look of the
animation as you can see here with a
smaller value of friction the animation
would go on for much longer
whereas when the friction is higher
naturally it accelerates the movement a
lot faster causing the animation to stop
a lot sooner and you can configure the
friction to - whatever that whatever
healthy value that looks good for your
animation the in addition to swing
animation was also introduced spring
animations in our new animation system
now first let's create the spraying
animation here - the constructor of the
spring animation we're going to supply
the object we want to animate in this
cases of view but it doesn't have the V
of you it can be any object and then the
property of all on animate in this case
is with a translation Y of the view and
then finally the resting position of the
spring now we're ready to start
so this animation would animate the view
from whatever translations that he had
at the start of the animation - back to
zero and here's what it looks like as
you can see them as I'm pulling this
with a little Android down it's moving
is translation Y while stretching the
screw the spring as it goes and then
once our Lego that
when the spray animation would start and
then the translation Y would start from
where I released it back to zero I mean
you can see it bounces back up and also
a little bit before a rest
translation Y of zero and if you feel
adventurous you can also change the
bounciness of the spring by simply
setting the damping ratio here we're
going to set the temperature to not
bouncy at all and that's what we see in
the animation if you look at this
animation then you feel like this
doesn't really match your taste for
spring animations we have an easy fix
you can simply change the damping ratio
to high bouncy and then you will have a
very bouncy animation with a lot of
oscillations before it finally settles
in addition to bouncing to dance
stamping ratio you can also change the
stiffness for the spring which will
control how quickly the object would
return to its resting position and we'll
take a look at that in a moment now
before you start the animation we can
also set some starting conditions for
the animations for example if we set the
star value to 200 this animation will go
from the translation Y of 200 back to
zero and also we can set the start
velocity to match the existing movement
of the object creating a continuous
motion we can also set the min value and
Max value like we did the first fling
animation and and define the range for
the animation now we're ready to start
so let's take a look at the stiffness
from low to high here we have if you
look on the very left when the SIF is
very low that the spring compresses
rather slowly after is stretched out of
its resting position so when the
stiffness gets higher towards the right
it bounces back up much faster and these
are the forced spring stiffness
constants that we have already defined
in our system because they each provide
a somewhat unique look
you can use one of these already defined
constants or you can use any positive
slope value for the spring stiffness in
your animation now that we've seen how
we can animate translations using spring
animations let's see what we can do when
we combine the rotation and translation
together in the spring animation here we
have an example of that as you can see
that this list flies in each individual
head sort of shakes around as if they
were hanging on to a clothesline that
we're pulling in to achieve this we need
to apply a rotational spring force on
usually individual head along with the
translation animation to slide this
whole list in first we need to rotate
each individual head we need to go
through all the items on the list and
for each item we'll need to create a
spring animation on its rotation
property and you may have noticed here
I'm using a different spring animation
constructor as we did before and this
constructors doesn't require a third
parameter which is the resting position
of this frame when using this
constructor the spring the animation
won't create a built in spring force and
na would instead expect a custom spring
force to be passed in and that's what
we're going to do we're going to create
a custom spring force of a resting
position of 0 and a damping ratio and
stiffness that looks good for this
particular animation arrived at through
careful experimentation and you may ask
why do we want to use a custom spring
force instead of the built in spring
force and the answer is by creating a
custom spring force we can then share
this spring force across all the spring
animations for the children no this is
only viable when all the spring
animations here expects the same spring
constants and the same
resting position and finally we can say
said the star value of the rotation
animation to minus 25 so the each head
was rotated from a minus 25 degree angle
and then oscillate around the zero
degree and eventually come to a stop
now that we've rotated each individual
head we still need to slide this whole
lesson now we can do that by creating a
spring animation for the list on its
translation X property and similar to
the rotation animation we're going to
configure the spring constants here
we're going to use the same spring
constants as we did before and finally
we're going to set the star value so
that the translation Y would start from
400 and then slide back into place so
we've seen spring animations on rotation
and on views translations what if you
want to animate something that's not a
view property but good knee of this
physics animation supports that here's
an example of that as you can see when I
have found the little mustache icon all
the items just pop in and blow up beyond
its normal size and insurance back down
making a very dramatic entrance and we
could achieve this by creating not one
but two spring animations for each
individual child one on is scalex
property the other one is scale Y
property so so the that each individual
head would be able to scale along both x
and y axis uniformly but that's a lot of
work now let me show you a different way
to do this imagine what if viewgroup had
this property that call it child scale
and whenever it's house killed changes
the view group would probably get down
that change to all those children in
both the skill X property and scale Y
property and I guess we can just animate
this one child scale for the
viewgroup and then we're done even
though new group doesn't really have
this property we can create one for is
here we're going to create a custom
property using full property comp ads
and we're going to have to override the
set value and get value whenever the
child skill changes we will receive this
serve a legal call back and in that like
we mentioned we're going to pass down
the change to all the children and then
change their skill X and skill Y
property uniformly and you know get
value well since we're assuming all the
children have the same skill we can just
return the skill of any any child in
this case we'll just return the first
child now that we've created this custom
property we can put it in an animation
so we're going to create an animation on
the child scale property for the lives
of beers and again we're going to set
the stiffness if you remember stiffeners
changes how how quickly the object
returned to its resting position here
because we want the scale change to be
more graceful we want to use a low
stiffness and finally we're going to set
a minimum visible change and this is the
method that we haven't seen before what
it does is it provides the animation
system and hints as to when it would be
a good time to stop so that the
animation doesn't go on for too long
without making any visible change on
screen and the reason 100 we haven't
seen those methods before in all these
previous examples is because up until
this example we had animated only the
filthy and view properties and when we
use it when we animate filty and view
properties the animation system can
derive such a value from based on which
animated which property is being
animated
he receives of if you create a custom
property you will need to provide the
smallest change in your custom property
that can make a visible difference
on-screen in our case we're animating
cow scale which is essentially of
a skill property so we're going to use
the already defined constant musical
change scale and then we get set the
star value to 0.5 so the scale animation
starts from a half scale and then and
then blow up and then eventually you
know it will settle a scale of 1 it's
normal size so we've talked about swing
animations we've also seen some cool
effects from the spring animations let's
see what we can create by combining
these two here we're going to use the
same example as we did our sim list as
we did for the swing animation as you
can see I'm playing the flips back and
forth but as the sling animation gets to
the end of the list there's still some
velocity loves there's still some
remaining energy and Delta when the list
starts to stretch out and snap back like
a rubber band this is a very playful way
for to dissipate the remaining energy
when arriving at the end of the list and
I think you'll agree with me this is a
much better experience than harshly
stopping the motion and losing all the
momentum in order to achieve this we
first need a fling animation and we're
going to just use the same swing
animation as we did before except this
time I'm going to call out to send Mia
value and set max value please define
the range of the animation like we
mentioned before but this range ensures
that the swing animation would end
immediately upon reaching either end of
the list and that's one we can start the
strand mission to then take over
whatever momentum that has it has left
so in order to start a spray and image
right after the four animations here
we're going to use them all night
emission update listener once the fling
animation finishes will receive this all
animation and call back with a full
animation and whether or not is canceled
and then the scrolling value and the
scrolling velocity
if the velocity is high enough so we're
going to create a spring animation for
the stretching effect and we're going to
create a spring animation for this whole
is on its skill X property so it can
stretch horizontally and as always we're
changing on the spring hostas to make
the animation looks good for this
particular case and finally we're going
to set the start philosophy here you
might notice I mean not using this
velocity that I received from this
callback because that's the scrolling
velocity which is a pixel-based and for
our skill animation who want something
that's um you know in in terms of scale
we can't do that conversion by simply
dividing the velocity by the size of the
menu
now before we start we still need to
configure one last name which is the
pivot point and for that's for the
scaling as you can see I'm really
fleeing this list back and forth and
depending on which way I'm playing it I
want the stretching to go the same way
as the scrolling direction so when the
velocity is negative the felicitous
flowing to the right and I want the
stretching to build towards the right as
well that requires us to pin the list on
its left side and we can do so by said
the pivot X to 0 similarly when the list
is growing to the left so want to pin
the list on his right side and we can do
so by set the pivot point to the right
side of the list which is the width of
this list but within usually individual
animations the human being each
individual spring animations in the past
lives and I think we can create
something that's more advanced and more
complex if we'll build on top of that
such as chin springs here we have three
views that are chained together via
spring force and you can see I'm
dragging the top view around and the
white circle indicates the dark point
and the other two views would follow as
the top view is moving around as if the
three of them were attached to each
other by a bungee cord now let's take a
look at how we can achieve this let's
name these three deals need a and B for
easy reference so our goal is to have a
follow the lead as lead is being dragged
around and B follow a and we're going to
achieve this by using spring animations
let's first take a look at how we can
have a follow the lead so first we're
going to create animations for a on its
translation X and translation Y
properties and you know talk to listener
where we're going to process the touch
events and
moobs leave you around we're going to
first for you move event we're going to
compare this event against the last
event in terms of positions and though
if we calculate the Delta and just felt
how it would be the amount of movement
of the finger and then we're going to
apply the Delta to the B's wheels
position so that the live view will be
moving the same amount as the finger
what's the easiest position is updated
one updates the position of or the
animation for a so it appears like a is
following the lead and here we're going
to use a method called enemy to final
position and we haven't seen this method
before they asked one of two ways if the
animation is not yet started this method
would set the final position for the
animation and start the animation if the
animation is already started it's
already running then this method is just
update the final position for the
animation and what this means is every
time we receive a move events we're
going to move the lead view and then if
a is that resting position we're going
to start an animation to move a towards
the V view if the a is already animating
then we're going to update a final
position so that if you remember in one
of the earlier earlier flies the way
physics based animation handled party
value change they would eventually after
some course corrections it would
eventually head towards the leave you
and this is how we achieve having a
follow the lead and finally we're going
to update the last position for the
motion event for the stealth hawk
calculation now let's take a look at how
we can have the follow a similarly we're
going to create animations for B and in
order to get notified whatever a
position is changed we need this home
animation update listener and we're
gonna add the listener to the A to C
then it's wave animation
in the Elm animation update callback
we're going to receive AZ animation and
then face position and is velocity we're
going to do the same trick here we're
going to call anim to final position so
if B is not moving at the moment in then
we would set the final position friend
and start the animation to move it
towards a or if B is already moving
we're going to update its final position
so eventually heads were they um so the
physics place in emissions is available
now you support like 26 feet of one and
you can use it by adding this dependency
to your Gradle file and it's backward
compatible to API 16
and I'm very excited to see what you
guys can come up with using this library
awesome so that was the cool new stuff
but what if you're still using the cool
old stuff so that's what I'm here for
so animator set there was long requested
functionality in terms of being able to
seek within an animation as well as
reverse we have this in the value
animator API but not in animator sets
because it was difficult to do so now we
have these capabilities and I'll show a
simple demo and some codes that's not
written in Collin and you can see how to
do that so there's a famous quote that I
think everybody probably knows seek and
you shall find it turns out that this
was taken out of context the full quote
goes something like this thinking you
shall find that there is no seek API on
animator set right it's nobody knew that
but I'm here to tell you that also it
turns out that there's no way to reverse
it but we did some things about that and
I'm going to show you how you can use
that functionality so here we have a
really simple rather lame demo what I
want to do given this amazingly complex
UI is move those three buttons around on
the screen when the user clicks on the
various controls there so in particular
when you play the animation I want the
button on top to move to the right the
button in the middle should move down to
the right and the button on the bottom
should move straight down so the button
when it moves to the right you create an
object animator fairly straightforward
we're going to animate translation X and
we're going to move it all the way over
until its positions all the way over on
the right the bottom of the button in
the middle we're going to move it to the
lower right similarly we create an
object animator we can use property
values holder so that we can animate X
and y at the same time inside the same
single object animator so we're doing
translation X and translation Y in
parallel and finally the button on the
bottom is going to move all the way to
the bottom of the screen similarly to
the one at the top it's going to animate
translation Y all the way down to the
bottom so we create these things
and then we create the animator set that
contains these child animations we're
going to run them in sequence so it's
going to go top middle bottom so we'll
play those sequentially and then we
start the animation which looks
something like this I bet you couldn't
guess what was going to happen there so
you press the play button animation
plays fairly straightforward that's what
you could do already but what happens if
we actually want to seek within the
animation well now we call this new
method called set current playtime so
we've hooked this up to the seek bar at
the top so when we get a call back into
the on progress change method we can see
where the seek bar is in that in that
track that it's in and interpret that as
a percentage of movement and then apply
that to the animator set animation so
set current play time using that
percentage multiplied times the total
duration that the animation has so we
have this get total duration method on
animator set we get that multiplied
times a percentage and away we go
so we drag it around on the screen
buttons move all the child animations
are moving independently depending on
where we seek in the animator set
animation itself all right and then
finally but you couldn't guess how this
is going to work what if we want to
reverse the animation so the user clicks
on the reverse button and everything
moves in Reverse very straight forwards
it turns out that the entire quote is
now amended and it's now until now so
please use reverse and seek
and get the capabilities that you want a
couple of notes on that one is that it
will specifically seek within child
animations that are a value animator
because if it's not a value animator or
an animator set we're not sure how to
how to reverse or seek that thing right
so if your child animation is just an
animator it's this opaque thing that
you've implemented we're not sure what
to do about it that will get dropped on
the floor or you can implement that
functionality but it's really
specifically for the common case of
value animators and object animators
subclass of that another thing to note
is there is new on animations start and
on animation and callbacks in the
interface default methods that we
implemented that will then provide you
the direction so in addition to knowing
when your starting and ending it's
useful if you know what direction you're
running in given the new capabilities
that animator set has so you can access
those as well and that is the talk and
we do have sure
[Applause]
[Music]